un jeu comme ça j'ai tombé un document
que vous le couvrir celle ap
c'est le plastique qui cède à vancouver
par la page à la zone gouvernementale
dégâts des imaginaires mais c'est
presqu'une protégé comme une visière
[Musique]
nous sommes là c'est le prix d'une
visière remporté ses deux marques pour
notre dessinée passe et pas seulement
alors dans le calcul avec dix mille
francs pour fabriquer un visuel dont je
ne compare les voir avec la médecine il
faut la prendre avec 70 vers le plus
proche est décédé et deux élever la
qualité attendue visière qualité
[Musique]
et ça s'est très bien passé déjà on
parle beaucoup et
de la maladie sur la griffe par le passé
les sept cas ce n'est pour nous pouvons
offrir tant que c'est mal
[Musique]